our economic system in its current form
is simply not advanced enough to
comprehend the consequences of its own
actions it is like a blind giant
lumbering from continent to continent
leaving incalculable ruin in its wake I
propose we give this giant a set of eyes
so that it might tread more gently and
maybe someday even look upon itself the
CEO of today will be judged not only by
how well we change our industries but
also about how well we lead our
companies to make positive impacts upon
them when choosing a leader you choose
on the behavior and what caused it good
it should show up with the grammar to
develop the way in which we are growing
things the way in which we are making
products providing services is having an
unexpected and disastrous impact on the
planet that we live on we need to change
in attitudes and new institutions to set
the right incentives so that what the
use becomes more efficient across the
world everybody who takes action
actually has an effect on suck at least
somebody and
we were the more influential you are the
bigger the impact there can be across
the world it's not less been working
together it's new ideas it's creating
new concepts and it's happening while we
speak it will challenge the way we think
it will challenge the way we work and it
will challenge the way we work with
artists there needs to be a more equal
division between the company owner and
the employee please take full
responsibility for your actions and your
in actions and leave a nice legacy for
our children and our grandchildren
extend hands and overcome obstacles to
make open trades and exchange of ideas
and the exchange of cultures and the
change of people easier in 2008 which
certainly helped make the planet a
better place in front
you